Israel y las hijas islámica Palestina
han alcanzado una tregua tras cinco días
de violentos enfrentamientos y varios
intentos fallidos de mediación de Egipto
Eso sí aunque debía entrar en vigor a
partir de hace diez de la noche hora
local los cohetes de la milicia y los
bombardeos israelíes se mantuvieron
hasta unos 20 minutos después Esto está
dentro de la dinámica habitual de ver
quién pone el punto final Pero también
es una muestra de lo volátil que puede
ser este César fuego que va a depender
de que se mantenga en la calma en las
próximas horas tanto del gobierno
israelí como las de milicias palestinas
agradecieron los esfuerzos de Egipto y
advirtieron que están listos para
retomar las hostilidades si hay nuevos
ataques al cabo de estos cinco días por
bombardeos israelíes el 33 palestinos
han muerto 15 de ellos civiles entre
ellos seis niños además de seis altos
mandos de nacijada islámica que también
vio destruidas en más de 370 de sus
instalaciones también han habido dos
víctimas del lado israelí por el impacto
de dos de los más de 1200 cohetes por
las hijas a la mujer israelí que
falleció el jueves se sumó y un gasati
que trabajaba en Israel y que fue
alcanzado por metralla de uno de los
proyectiles en yoqueda en gaza en tanto
esperan que el César fuego permita la
pronta reapertura de los cruces con
Israel que posibilita el ingreso de
mercancías y combustible al enclave y
que pacientes con cáncer u otras
enfermedades puedan reanudar sus
tratamientos en Israel O sí Jordania una
próxima prueba para las tensiones se la
llamada marcha de las banderas el jueves
el desfile anual de extremistas judíos
que atraviesa el barrio musulmán de la
ciudad vieja de Jerusalén y que es
considerado una provocación por los
palestinos